going on an adventure today we're gonna
find some people meet him and live their
life with him can I come with you that's
on the ask people
hi there what were you headed
small you session can I come with you no
I'm headed to a meeting in two minutes
ah could I go with you yeah really
no no what are you all waiting for who's
that what time's the show
I can't go to that yeah maybe I'll have
a taco party all right hey doing hi I'm
Keith
nice to meet you Johnny where you headed
I'm headed home could I come with you
uh it wouldn't be the best time my
roommate is uh very hungover you want to
call him he he is on crutches right now
then he needs support of friends they
want to support you I don't know I don't
know it's just me my buddy Zach Louise
and Kyle so like two cameraman and one
sound guy and me sweet alright we go
alright peace out buddy
we're going over have you said your name
is Jason Johnny Johnny
thanks remembering that up real quick so
Johnny where are you from I'm from New
York why'd you move out here I'm an
actor
oh nice what's your coolest thing I'm in
I'm in hand to God on Amazon oh yeah
that's sick Ron Perelman does that pay
you good uh where's the soccer party's
gonna be later what up taco party Johnny
you were gonna go get groceries at
Trader Joe's before we came yeah but
then we interrupted you so we're
actually gonna go make sure you run your
errands first cuz I don't want to cover
your whole day
I just got kicked out of the store so I
hope Keith a new friend are having a
good time so you're gonna carry my
groceries yeah so we're gonna go meet
Miguel now yep at your house and Kramer
and Kramer the dog here cuts at 12 bucks
right there for a washing cut that's not
bad not for me he'll charge me like a
girl are you actually going through whoo
through the chili earlier honey through
the Batman Ali who's sofa this is nice
oh yeah I forgot about this and you pray
1,800 for this yeah
nice that's a steal buddy a Tuesday all
right what a fun Tuesday were having
yeah what's next I can see why you were
cast in some Amazon shows so you just
live with this construction noise all
the time huh yeah it's kind of
I deal yeah I hear Miguel up there yeah
here's Miguel ionic body walking down
hey how are you he could I come up to
you are you decent brushing his teeth
should I shoot this big thing with the
biohazard symbol on it yeah oh it did
what I thought it would
how do I so Miguel good coming in hot
making fun of everybody's plaid we're
gonna clear things up we're gonna get a
cool sexy TV show format to interview
Miguel hey what's up we're here live
from Johnny and Miguel's apartment the
person we've all been waiting to meet
Miguel how are you I'm doing well there
sir the real elephant in the room ago
you got crutches you got a bum foot
there oh right yeah I'll show you I'm a
bartender and I was polishing some
glasses snap the glass stabbed myself in
the hand right 20 minutes later I go to
go under the bar and the wine stem is
still on the ground standing straight up
and I step on it and it goes through my
shoe stabs me in the foot up and I'm
like oh my god it's in there it's in
there I pull this thing out blood is
just pouring out onto the floor of the
bar
Ruiz threw my chute huh I get to the
table I'll take my shoe off and then
just blood just started pouring out
gross yeah oh yeah it's still black and
blue on top yeah oh yeah you got
something jabbed up in your foot once
what what do you do out here as of late
I've been doing some screenplay writing
well tell them what the movie is about
oh all right sure so it's a three girls
on spring break in in Spain and they're
leaving Madrid they're going to
Barcelona but along the way they find
this charming charismatic Spaniard man
this never works out well he traps them
and basically uses their bodies as
fertilizer for his vineyard
yeah we'd love to cut to a clip of the
movie so here it is I hope you guys
enjoy it
waiter I'm sorry but do you have any
chocolate of any kind of course we do we
have the sort of bonbons well I'll take
three orders and thank you for being so
pleasant did you just order three orders
of bonbons and don't forget the cheese
and charcuterie plate I haven't been
this high and hungry in over two decades
I will murder you and put you in my
garden came from wow I think we can all
say that was a pretty impressive piece
of work guys that whole laugh was
exactly how I pictured it I don't know
if we are actually deserving of any
Oscars for what we did today but I think
we're all deserving of some tacos so I'd
love for you guys to meet me Zak and I
are gonna go on and head to Calle tacos
the taco place we would love to sponsor
us so that we can have tacos every
Tuesday making every Tuesday Taco
Tuesday ah yeah it's your buddy Keith
and I got ten hours for a shotgun
Tuesday
yeah I got tongue goes in the bag I got
tacos and mangoes the bag all right it's
been an amazing day I made a new friend
Johnny new friend Miguel I bet a lot of
ladies in tacos for Taco Tuesday thank
you for letting me come with you
who is James Bay hahaha
really I